he's none of than Josh Rosen how you
doing Josh very good are you I'm good
your seats on your seats look good man
the seats still look good did you sign
it a long time ago glad to hear I heard
those short these are permanent they are
permanent gotta be careful
how's everything in Miami for you Josh
walk we through that to start off our
converse idea it's going really well
just finally getting settled in I mean
I'm finding my way around the building
I'm not walking in the receiver rooms
thinking their bathrooms any more in
figuring out where everything is
breaking down this playbook and getting
used to this heat a little bit okay
they're not having a really good time
it's and I'm just sort of more and more
excited each day well I know sometimes
I'm not to get too deep in the weeds
here sometimes when you do walk in the
bathroom you know you're thinking about
getting your business done already
started did that already did that happen
when you walked into the receiving room
think it was a bathroom I mean you know
there's like like a 30 40 % chance in
exactly that whatever room I walked into
it's not that room I'm employing a
playbook the entire bed Wow okay well
that's great so in terms of getting
acclimated the the offense we had Trent
Dilfer on he said he actually texted you
this that this is perfect for you
that it's going to challenge you
mentally that you are going to be out
there having some aspect of it within
your control and it's going to challenge
you in a way that you really like would
you agree with that assessment Josh yes
absolutely I mean I missed the first
month here so whatever challenges were
presented were mounted a little even
more so yeah I mean this place book is
awesome I mean it's it's straight from
the Patriots with a couple flavors from
some assistant coaches from other places
I mean I got a really good relationship
with Coach Polinsky already and I'm
really excited for what this to do I
mean I'm learning I'm learning new
football each day not just within our
playbook but goes called those
stationary things that he's been
preaching his whole career so I think
it's a really good spot for me I'm
really excited to to keep working kind
of my motto is just
just improve each day to whatever the
degree whether it be a lot or a little
it's just keep kind of poverty of
forward momentum and hopefully after a
couple weeks a couple weeks months and I
can look back over my shoulder and
realize I've come a pretty long way
now when you mentioned call well I mean
Jim Caldwell obviously has had some
quarterbacks of note that he has coached
have you reached out to Peyton Manning
at all as have you picked his brain
whatsoever
not directly we've crossed paths a
couple times he's been he's been really
awesome
I'm gives me some really good advice but
uh I haven't I've actually reached out
to him for for those kind of purposes
okay and argue you are in a quarterback
competition essentially would you agree
with that that is what is happening with
you in Miami yeah I know it just it just
seems again for for somebody with your
journey to show up there and be in that
position and this is absolutely no
disrespect whatsoever to Ryan
Fitzpatrick it seems like this should be
a show for you to showcase what what the
Dolphins acquired here Josh I'm
wondering how you approach it well I
mean I think you just kind of have to
step back a little bit and realize where
you are
you know I was at the 10th overall in us
as anchor it wasn't first but at the
same time is still a first-round draft
pick and I still have an opportunity
computer another team and we had a lot
of guys here that are probably they're
undrafted rookies that came here a
couple days ago and they got something
proven they would love to be in my shoes
so I mean I I like you can be frustrated
with three or but I don't think you can
ever lose perspective you know I'm in
Miami playing this beautiful game with a
lot of guys that want to compete and I
mean I think in terms of in terms of
guys to compete with with I guess my
kind of personality profile I don't
think there's a better guy could get
along with the Rockets Patrick had some
great conversation so far I think our
quarterback runes been a lot of fun he's
really goofy but he really loves to work
and I think he's gonna make me better
I'm gonna make him better and I think
complacency is kind of a killer in this
league and I think quarterback the
competition in general is sort of the
exact opposite of a kind of kills
complacency
Rosen here on the Rich Eisen show
alright I'm gonna give you the floor on
this one Josh what do you say to people
think that you were ducking competition
in Arizona Josh I wasn't okay what I
mean I don't really there's there's no
indication at any point that I was I was
literally in Arizona until the one
minute before the draft I got a call
from quest saying that they're about to
drop Tyler but I mean I mat for a
millisecond was shying away from
competition so that's when you got a
call literally one minute before the
Cardinals were put on the clock that's
when you heard from Coach Kingsbury that
that that you did so you didn't have to
learn from it from the television set
Josh is that how it went down
yeah I mean my my agent gave me a call
about five minutes before saying don't
be surprised this might happen and I was
like I know what it is is what it is
we'll see how the cards card slot cards
end up falling but I mean I'm gonna
compete wherever I am so cliff gave me
actual call a minute before it happened
saying that we're gonna draft Tyler and
I mean I have the most respect for cliff
I mean I I don't let anyone for making
business decisions that they think are
best for them and their family but I
just really appreciated how he just kind
of acted like a man and was very
respectful he was wishing me the best he
called me even the day after the draft
wishing me good luck and I wish them
good luck I even gave I have a gift I'll
call shot him a text and said good luck
wish me the best but um I mean that's
kind of the all you can really ask for
in this game is just people make
decisions for whatever reasons but as
long as they're men about it and they
respect someone else's career that I can
appreciate that
well did you ask Kingsbury before you
hung up are you gonna trade me did you
did that question come out here out to
basically say well what are you gonna do
with me Josh I mean I don't know if I
did say but like literally he's like hey
so we're got stress Tyler I don't really
know what happens now but yeah and I
responded I was like yeah I don't really
know what happens either but I mean
regardless at least the game the
courtesy give me
I mean I love everyone in that building
with the exception maybe one or two guys
that are but for the most part I love
every single one everybody in that
Arizona Cardinals Building from some Tom
Reed the trainer to Bret Fischer the
Pete's either to I mean the the kitchen
crew so the the Clint it was an
unbelievable experience that an awesome
time I belong to move on but I'm very
excited and it was it's very interesting
right but uh the interest makes the
story a little better yeah I know and so
I was gonna ask you to describe now that
you are a couple of weeks removed and
maybe some of the raw emotions that you
were feeling at the time have subsided
how how would you describe yourself
looking back as to what did happen with
you with the Arizona Cardinals Josh
Rosen I don't know I mean I think this
is kind of unprecedented so I don't
really have any kind of foundation on
how I should feel
all I know is that it's happening I
think reflection is more for down the
road right now I'm kind of in it so I'm
just keeping my head down but yeah I
mean the only thing that like truly did
kind of frustrate me through this whole
process that I still haven't heard from
my old GM like I didn't talk to him for
months before still haven't talked to
him months after but that was kind of
frustrating but for the most part it's
I'm just ready to put that whole chapter
behind me and keep pushing on and and
playing football
did you ever connect with Tyler on the
song no I never end up did but never
ended up actually connecting with them
but I mean I'm that's the one thing I've
kind of learned since being in the NFL
is that we're playing teams versus teams
but but we're all were all rooting for
each other
I mean players the players were all
we're all in a union together we're all
working together busting our butts and
that's one thing that I think is really
cool about the NFL versus college is
that after the game when when you break
the sideline you guys are kind of saying
hey or saying what's up to old teammates
there's that's kind of cool because
everyone at some point usually worked
with someone or played with someone so
it's pretty fun to see that it'll happen
and you kind of realize that we're all
in this together so I really couldn't be
rooting more for Tyler
I just in the route more for us here why
are you saying that nicely about
calamari because you're still trying to
rent that condo in Arizona you have not
got it's still avail I mean I'd like to
help you move move the real estate if
you need some right here on the Rich
Eisen show so that has still not been
rented or leased or anything like that
it has not we were putting it on the
market soon I don't know I I don't think
I'm gonna give the actress out okay
that's fine yes no it's a right an old
town great spot to love it
I describe it as kind of a man cave a
bedroom so I got a ping-pong table and
there start board video games and stuff
so it's been a fruiting me well for you
but no hot tub right no no a wool there
is one in the building okay not in my
actual unit there you go you're all
grown stuff Josh let everybody letting
everybody know that you are grown up
you're a grown-ass man right now in the
national football is that the
qualifications
oh my gosh look I'm happy you're in a
spot where you're competing and you got
a large future in front of you Josh I've
said it before I'll say it again
you know dolphins are lucky to have you
and I appreciate you calling in and
checking in absolutely not thanks for
having me I really appreciate it you got
it and you still you still do follow the
Rich Eisen show accounts correct I want
to make sure cuz you were you were
hitting that unfollow button a few weeks
ago I just want to make sure was no no I
got you don't worry III was I hear your
frustration with your with your alma
mater trying to sign a new coach
I heard the rant the other day
I wouldn't call it a rant per se but
I'll tell you Josh I'm genuinely
concerned abut I I don't want to get
look I think I think you got to look out
for the Bruins I think that it hasn't
been too great behind them
got a couple new buildings from new
coaches okay thank you like Cronin I
think you're old you gotta watch out for
the Bruins I'm here you're all in on
Chloe right because I was gonna tell you
man I mean we're both living in that
glass house right now on the basketball
front so you know just wanted to point
that out but I appreciate look
everything about you man i I just really
am rootin very hard for you and I look
forward to seeing how it all works out
in Miami for you thank you I really
appreciate that you got a Josh thanks to
call but we'll see people chat soon
absolutely no problem you got that Josh
3 Rosen on Twitter for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app